pogchamps 3 is brought to you by grip 6.
grip 6 is an american manufacturing
company dedicated to making the very
best belts
wallets and wool socks grip 6 built to
wear
not to wear out visit gripsix.com
pogchamps
[Music]
wow well benji needs all the support you
can get because sardocia's rating is
14.50
what what have they been feeding this
guy oh i don't know i'm nervous
but i i really hope for benji oh
apparently he's a jungler this is so
awkward
oh um never mind you'd like to take back
everything i said
a lot of awkward moments here
i feel like it gets less awkward if you
just make it public right i just
put candy in my mouth it was like a
weird
distraction yes black has the pawn chain
towards the center
white devotes the bishop to d3 so often
when the bishop develops
now is the time that black takes because
you don't get to recapture in one move
but the players are leaving the tensions
the sign that they've
been improving that they've been
studying because i think when you're
less experienced you take as quickly as
possible
when given the opportunity
i agree
would it be what would you do next here
well
the thing is not a single piece has been
traded so that's i would say the
uh struggle right now is what to do
because nothing's been traded and
benji plays b3 to protect his sponsor
with another pawn
and well sodor says i'm going to play h6
and they're actually playing a really
high level game this to this point
taking on f6 would unnecessarily give up
the bishop pair
whereas this knight's not really going
anywhere it can move
but then you're willing to trade the
bishops and this knight has nowhere good
to move so
by not trading cutie they're leaving
this tension and creating
difficulties for their opponent so it's
just not restricting their opponent's
chances to play something active perhaps
a trade here right because the bishop
that's his option he could take or he
could just ignore it
so he does okay there we go we have a
trade
they are recognizing that pieces can
come off the board don't need to keep
them all
proud of this development one of the big
things here cutie is
this pawn structure for white is really
strong
and when you have a pawn chain the pawn
chain is only as strong as the base of
its chain so the f2 pawn is very safe
so what black wants to do in the near
future is play e5 to start chiseling at
the pawn chain to create the bass
closer to black pieces and make it
easier to attack it
yeah that's what i always do too i know
you do you're a stonewall player so
you know about pawn chains f5 you saw
the engine drop and the reason why
is this pawn on e5 lost its defender so
chest often is about timing
and now that black took this pawn e5 is
going to be
one that can quickly get under attack so
rook takes f5 here
will defend the pawn temporarily but
then this bishop can slide back to c8
attack the rook and become useful for a
change
you're right though bishop back was
better the rook on a7 would have
protected but look at this
this pawn was under attack but now it's
pinned and if benji sees it
bishop takes g6 steals a pawn
did you see benji he kind of threw
himself back in his chair i think he
sees it
fingers crossed okay
he's got his hand up he feels ready to
play his move
he's down under three minutes sardosha
had the clock but that was a
big swing if benji takes that pawn he
does
he takes it nice okay
i am getting nervous for benji's time a
little bit
i am as well and i think he's trying to
figure out because
this bishop is hitting the queen and the
rook on the same diagonal
that's a problem for him he needs to see
that his bishop can just retreat back
which saves the material and still
leaves black's king
out in the open
uh we're spending too much time and i i
don't think he sees it
based on the time consumption no i don't
think he sees it either
that's the hardest thing and this is
gonna be very stupid and you guys gonna
be like yeah forehead cutie
uh to remember is that your your bishops
can move back
any sacrifice the rook
i actually don't think it's stupid at
all i think that's a mistake that is
very commonly made
one of the hardest things to find in
chess is retreating night moves
and treating moves in general are easily
missed all the time and now
the problem for benji is he lost a rook
for a bishop he still has
attacking chances but the rook for
bishop dynamic
should be good for sutter if he can
handle this well there but there's still
pressure
and i don't think that sodos is out of
the woods yet
i i think he's pretty safe to start
playing oh
oh he did it no my gosh he did it he
called it he's being checkmated
by force come on does he see it
i thought it was my analysis board for a
second and then i looked and no
the engine's got he does see it there he
sees it oh
gosh oh no queen f6 it's all forest it's
all force it's mate
it's it's checkmate on the spot that's
it's done
and look at
[Music]
foreign
i think 12. he plays fortnite
and let's see when the checkmate happens
if we get a reaction look how happy he
is
there he is oh my gosh
but i'm going to say i want sardosh to
win now
because he was sad and i'm sad for him
so you really are flip-flopping here
yeah i feel bad when it hurts to lose in
chess
it does it hurts it's not a simple it's
not like
league of legends you can blame your
jungler all you can do in chess when you
lose is blame your coach and it doesn't
feel the same
whoa whoa why the coaches got well i
mean yes it's always the coach's fault
but
why i felt i felt like a sort of
attack in a way i just
i just this is just it's just hard i
don't know it's just hard
yeah no i'm with you and i don't think
that the players
i think they really have been
appreciative of all the coaching they've
received and
benji right now up one nothing this is
a london type of setup the bishop drops
back to g3
because if black takes on g3 the h pawn
replaces the bishop
and there's whoa look at benji fishy
just blitzing this out
he's been working on this very clearly
and i'll look at benji he knows the
plans this is
not someone memorizing an opening this
is somebody understanding because he
brought his bishop
back to e7 he didn't like the pin here
and
now you have the bishop on d3 you have
the bishop on h4
but lining up an attack is difficult
because one of the best ways to stop an
attack
is by creating threats elsewhere in the
board and with this tension all over the
place here in the center
white doesn't have a free hand on the
king side
so much tension here cute you know what
time it is
no i thought there could be a stonewall
situation with that pond going after
that is not a stone wall do you even
know the stonewall that's not the
stonewall how dare you
i asked you to teach me but you're too
busy teaching pokey and code mikko and
everybody else
that's not the stone wall i'm sorry
i'm sorry gm's these days they don't
even know all the freaking openings
that's crazy
i'm sorry embarrassing for you honestly
oh oh oh oh oh uh oh
when pieces are in line with the queen
you go and try to pin them
oh that was a rush decision still a good
position for
sardosh but go back a half step here
rook to c1 or queen to c4
you pile up and you pin the piece and
win the piece so this would have been
a great opportunity for starters to
level the match instead he takes on c6
and his idea is that when the queen
takes on c6 he will take on d4
white will still be a pawn ahead so it's
a good decision
it makes sense but he had a move that
would have netted more material he did
move that really quickly
yes and there are actually some devious
threats here that black needs to be very
careful about
because i could see this ending in a
checkmate pretty soon for white here it
goes after queen takes queen takes a2
if you take this in comes the queen of
d8 with check
and after king h7 there's knight e7
trying to bring the queen here
and checkmate this king and there's big
danger for black
this could be very scary okay
let's see wait check okay 97. oh my gosh
oh oh no watch out here so the
move that black should play is push your
f pawn because benji's queen is actually
eyeing the g8 square through the pawn so
push that pawn up the board oh wow and
you can save the day
you can save the day here and look at
benji deep in thought
what a cool mate i love any mates with
with a knight i think they're very cool
this you really don't see this very
often but it's because black's pieces
are all
out over there on the queen side not
helping the king and
you're asking you know when can you burn
the king out not in this position
even a queen at night that's enough
material to land a checkmating attack
so this is very scary for benji he's
thinking he needs to push the pawn
i think that there's no other way to
save the king besides pushing the pawn
up the board
i hope he sees it i don't i don't i
i think he will just because he
surprised me a few times and you know
he's desperately looking right now
you know that he knows that there's got
to be a way
and he could be thinking about pushing
the pawn up to make space for the king
the problem is the queen will stop on g8
then go to h8 and this king is going on
a walk up the board
and actually checkmated in the next move
after queen takes pawn so let's show
that very quickly
if h5 queen g8 up keep check it's force
checkmate there's nothing that black can
do and that would be
a checkmate wow
let's see no move yet no move played by
ben oh
he's got a minute come on veggie oh and
he's not streaming so we can't see oh
oh no uh it's gonna be this exact
checkmate it's going to be the checkmate
here comes sodor sees it no question
he's going to do this mate
oh boy oh boy
oh oh he blew the queen oh my gosh oh my
gosh you blunted the queen
does benji see it does benji see it
benji do you see this oh he has to see
it look at benji's face he's in shock
oh he took the queen and sardosh loses
the queen
benji is so confused
no the tragedy not the queen
[Music]
oh my god benji is smiling sardosa is
melting
he's melting oh no
sartosh played a great game and that's
so frustrating in chess you play a
fantastic game
he was playing so well and on
one turn doesn't see the queen on the
opposite the board
full board awareness needs to see these
things and unfortunately for sodos
queens he is laughing at himself he is
laughing at himself
at least he's not crying well it's a
botez gambit for the ages
and benji fishy wins
a great match by benji but did get the
benefit of that blunder there
both of these players look like serious
contenders and benji fishy
wins the group two nothing in this match
and we are back with both players
benji fishy wins two nothing over
sardosh both of you played amazingly
well i have to say that
i think this was the closest match and
the best played match of the entire
event
so benji i want to start with you can
you just tell everybody what you've been
doing how much you've been practicing
and it is clearly paying off uh yeah
i've been practicing as much as i can uh
you know i've got like
fortnite tournaments but you know
whenever i have spare time
um i i just really enjoy playing it's a
this is a
nice hobby of mine i i just really enjoy
and i want to
i'm a competitive guy so i want to get
you know as good as possible at it
for sure and so does what about you um
every time i open twitch you're playing
chess or studying with a new coach
seems like you're taking this very
seriously and you did play great chess
of course both games ended on what's you
know look like blunders on your end but
you were really playing well throughout
my life
i don't know i uh first of all it was
one of my intense game uh i played for
my whole life so i wasn't used to be
focused for so long in a chess game
for us at first and then
well i i'm a bit sad because i lost both
game boss game because of
tactics i was supposed to be
slightly worse than benji
concerning positional stuff and close
position because he used to
close the position and uh i used to open
up i
play an open silent play well i couldn't
play my stuff
and he trained he prepared very well
against my london system so
i i was a bit confused at first but i
always managed to get
out of the first position better and
i get too confident i guess so i'm super
i'm super ashamed actually to
that i have done this mistake because i
already expected to win this tactic and
lose with strategy and i'm so sad man
what the
no you played amazing and i know
obviously the result stings but i have
to reiterate that time and time again
you
really played excellent even in this
moment i brought up the boarder you're
talking about positional
[Music]
you